it's 30 in the blowfish here so Darius
do you want to introduce the starting
lineup here Brian guitar young Fargo and
basin gym sauna failed on drums and Dan
Patrick on rubber-chicken
yes what was the what was the second
name that you guys were looking on
aside from hooting the Blowfish that's
the only name mark and I were used to be
the wolf brothers but the worst name
Dean wanted to call us black and blue
could they all had blue eyes that was
black black and blues yes I do think the
name did help you guys like it or hate
it you never forget it and so I think it
did help us because people could
remember yes no one forgot the name and
there was something about that but at
any point did you guys think we should
change the name oh yeah yeah yeah
basically when Sony got in the band took
a good hard look at it we were playing
clubs and we were like we should
probably change the name but we were
already doing so well in a few places we
don't want to start all over we're gonna
change the name you start all over we
were drawing hundreds of people but also
when you look at this we always look at
an overnight success but it took like 20
years for an overnight success or 10
years for you guys but when I met you
guys in what 94 you guys had been
playing at frat houses and whatever for
at any point how close did you guys come
to just saying this ain't going to
happen
never yeah we thought about like when we
got our record deal
we weren't even looking for a record
deal we were doing so well in the club's
we were making we were playing the same
clubs every six weeks making you know we
all make it over fifty thousand dollars
a years of playing clubs we were we were
content we weren't even looking for a
record deal so you got free drinks women
and you're making independent and you're
paying the bills yeah yes perfect but
when you have hold my the importance of
holding my hand to this band oh was it
first of all Sony when he came to
audition for the band
the first thing he did was said I got a
song we said play your song and it was
hold my hand and so we were like you're
in the band bro it's also the song that
David Letterman heard and hey I want
that band on my show and then that was
the appearance that sort of broke the
ice so yeah there's a pretty important
song for us yeah because I wondered that
where you look at these bands and then I
didn't know if you guys were worried
about being a one-hit wonder we weren't
cuz we by the time we got to recording
cracker review we had been playing let
her cry for several years we've been
playing only want to be with you for
several years in the clubs and hold my
hand
you know so we had kind of a small
little catalog of songs that we're
working as well as hold my hand in the
bars that's that's the testing ground
you can get 200 people in a in a club to
sing along with you and then by your
creditable cassette for five bucks and
take it home because they liked it that
much
you're those are songs they're gonna
gonna last what was it like to hear that
song on the radio for the first time oh
it was it was amazing
it was I mean freaked us out I think you
just stare at the radio think it was
funny for us it was one moment where it
was too much I was I was in Charleston
and I'm driving on the road and I got a
radio on and the hoodie song comes up
and so I changed the channel this
laughter everything was big and I
changed the channel and the next channel
it was a hoodie song and I changed the
channel in the next channel who was a
different hoodie so on and I changed it
a fourth time and it was time was the
fourth one and that was on and I went oh
my goodness I really went oh my goodness
world every radio station in this town
it was crazy but what happened that
first taste of success I paid off my
student loans what about you good for us
it was like kind of a gut check of like
hey this is we're gonna do this is what
we really wanted to do is we're a
passion about and we're gonna get we're
gonna do this forever I'll be honest
with you we didn't see the only success
we saw was that we were the shows would
get bigger because we were always on the
road it was never anything but touring
so the show
getting bigger great yeah I think it was
also when when we got a deal with BMW to
be the South Carolina ambassadors and
got three cars I was like okay you guys
open up for big head Tottenham on
sprocket was second I was yeah and in
the middle of the tote or you could tell
everything had changed I mean really you
in the middle of the tour do you guys
flip-flop yeah we've done on stage but
people coming to see us flip-flop yeah
yeah and then Toad the Wet Sprocket
decided to dissolve the band I think the
REM was a big influence you you make
mention of Stipe in a song yeah or two
why was REM why did what's that the same
with everybody else that don't worry I'm
kind of raised we were in college that
was that that was like the alternative
scene was coming up and they were the
basically the poster children for the
alternative seated at and their music
was really influential on a lot of
people and we were one of those bands
and I mean we grew up with him too I
mean being in Columbia there from Athens
I think first time Darius and I went and
saw him at the township it was like half
full and the went back the next year and
it was sold out and so I mean it that
and we just listened to him to death
yeah when I joined the band in 89
it should have said hooey the Bluefish
and that in parentheses and REM cover
back they sent me a demo of like a
cassette of like 30 songs and 18 of them
were REM something we had 12 or a
favorite cover song for each one of you
guys to play oh good question
interstate love song is what we keep
going on yeah just rocks and we we do
this thing in the middle of all only
want to be with you where we play get
down on it by cooling the game I love
that every day I still can't believe we
could play that I love it
Dean what about you I mean interstate
love songs a great one champagne another
great one we used to open up the set
with the song by this band called the
rave ups called
how long you keep on telling me want to
be happy
that was killer
you can't curse how come all the stuff
comes out on me must be it was great it
was that good yes then you did fight the
power we do we do fight the power it was
oh it was so funny you know we we were
opening up for Jason Aldean and uh this
in Atlanta and they're in there in their
baseball stadium and we've to fight the
power and some uh some country DJ comes
on and he's telling everybody to burn
our records cuz we're we're singing a
fight the power
oh my god Brigid kidding me I was like
Jack are you fool we played that song
for 27 years I was like making us
political hilarious why did people turn
on Hootie and the Blowfish it was so big
it was so big just every I mean that I
mean it's a great problem to have yes
but but it felt like they were mad at
themselves for liking you guys like I
like how did I like the I'm so mad at
myself I'm gonna take it out on somebody
and wasn't there the bumper sticker
maybe you saw it more than that in
Baltimore or something honk if you hate
Hootie no just now it's come full circle
it is it is it's so funny
for me because uh back back in 96 I want
a that GQ Man of the Year and music and
the whole story the last paragraph the
guy says the war of Hootie the Blowfish
you guys will get respect when Jon Daly
is on the UH when John Daly is on the
Senior Tour and sure enough I remember
seeing the New York Times article before
the tour started and I think I sent it
to you because I got it on Saturday and
it was the Sunday edition and I went I
think I sent it to Sony too I go what
the because I said it took this long for
then these critics to kind of circle
back and go you know what on second
thought yeah it's like critics did the
same thing like you know they're it's
simple like what is this and and now I
think that it's great to see that they
kind of had this epiphany and said you
know what second thought they were
pretty you sold 25 million of cracked
rear-view right yeah
worldwide I think critics
couldn't like us because we had just
killed the form of music that they
adored so much you know we had just wait
what did you kill grunge
if you look at the if you look at the
timeline when hoody came drenched in it
that's when maxbox pretty got their deal
and all those 94 yeah is when is really
when that's like they start playing on
the radio when we started playing on you
take credit for killing the Blowfish
joining us here in the man cave and
their new album imperfect circle will be
available everywhere and that is
starting today for the commercial break
I tease that there was an incident on
the road many many many years ago that
you you told me now is that the craziest
moment you've had on the road where he
got into a fight no we had the
Albuquerque was a great fight we got we
got to fight in a in our mission okay
we're in this bar in Ann Arbor and it's
us we meet Tiger an 18 year old Tiger
Woods for the first time and the Stanley
Cup shows up at this ball from the Red
Wings and so we're walking out and we're
just walking and all of a sudden snow
we're throwing snowballs with these guys
and we think it's funny and all of a
sudden Oh snowball hits the wall and
it's got a bottle in it whoo it's got a
bottle in it and all of a sudden I'm
looking at Sony and Sony runs across the
street and yeah I'm like if Sony's going
I'm going
sweet and we're like a scene out of
Braveheart
you guys are sony's under the car
so knees under the car beating one guy
and the other guy jumps in his car he's
trying I'm punching him in the car is
too why are you guys famous no no we
were just starting to we were playing
out of string of clubs I was just
starting to take off we just did Tiger
get involved in this no he we left him
in the bar okay that would be the great
the Albuquerque real quick okay
when Albuquerque Sony's got a hat on and
the bouncer comes upstairs where we are
it says take your hat off takes he takes
his hat off God thinking these little
little buzz puts it back on balance
Alaska's take a hat off Ken takes a hat
off goes upstairs we're all having a
great time having a great time party and
we looked down on these three cowboys
walking with their cowboy hats on we
wait for about 15 or 20 minutes and
nobody tells him to take the hats off so
when he put his hat back on
so it's about five or six of us up there
and we look up and we see five or six
bouncers walking up the steps so we
instantly know what so on so they're the
guys yelling so nice look our security
guy buddy puts the Sony on the way push
your Sony out of the way and goes you
know don't talk to him talk to me and in
about 15 seconds on I mean we're gonna
fill up our bar flight-ready house I
grew up fight there's no big deal no big
thing to me so I'm fighting I'm fighting
my guy and I'm doing really well I'm
looking around and I realize everybody
in Hootie the Blowfish is killing sodium
just destroyed this guy Morgan just like
worked on even fight and we're like all
of a sudden so we whoop these guys we
whoop these guys and we're leaving and
as we leave the owners walk the owner
comes up cuz the cops gonna show up and
everything was a bar fight let me tell
you you know me then when I'm mad I'm
really mouthy um I'm mad and I said you
need to get some new bounce he's like
what are you talking about I was like
you need new bouncers who need a
bullfight just whooped everybody I do
not just say Public Enemy I said buddy
benchpress a guy or not that's standing
pressed a guy bigger than him dropped
him on a pool table the greatest move
I've ever seen in a fight but he's kind
of short buddy was here security right
he's short and buddies fighting this guy
but he's looking around and make sure
everybody's okay you know I could tell
he's looking to make sure everybody's
okay and he trips over a pool table the
buddy short so buddy's on his pool table
his feet aren't on the ground and
big guy sees buddy Jen he jumps on buddy
and buddy took this guy
straight up in the air and slammed him
so hard on the on the pool table
everybody
[Laughter]
I wish felt cell phones were big then
because I would love to see that because
I'm telling you I looked around and said
we are killing these guys I'm like wow
y'all y'all need some new bouncers in
here but did you ever have any of those
moments on stage cuz I I've stood next
to buddy your bodyguard and I go dude
you got the easiest job ever
well real quick you can vase over here
and nobody cares I'm doing this thing
I'm playing I'm playing the club I'm
playing a club some radio show from a
country band and I see these two boys
these two guys talking and one guys tell
his buddy I'm going up and there's a
buddy he's like I'm not going so sure
enough I see him and here he comes so I
just back off and I see it and buddy
comes running it's on it's on the
internet and buddy hit this guy like
Michael Strahan coming off the corner
again he just took this guy out and so
the guy goes down and long story short
about about a week later we get our
lawyer to send us a letter and if the
letter says that the guy suing us
and buddy you know buddy the other guys
in a wheelchair he's suing everything
and so buddy is like waiting for me to
be the yeah I'm always the reason and
we'll be all right we'll handle this and
I looked at buddy and said oh my god I
can't help you and I said oh man the
Laura fees alone we mess with him for a
day but you know and I told this story
before when you guys were in Vegas and
you got word that Bob Dylan wanted a
couple hundred thousand dollars crazy
and so you sampled from Bob Dylan we
then said well we use we the lyric yeah
what I don't understand how that works
we've used a considerable lyric and had
gotten permission to do it just a year
or two earlier on an early on the saying
yeah the same song only want to be with
you what
actually said was it wasn't we didn't
rip him off it was actually a tribute to
him and they were fine that we used it
yeah yeah so we did the exact same song
a year later just rerecorded the exact
version for cracked review and it became
a huge hit and suddenly their lawyers
needed to come back and say well you
didn't get permission to do it at the
second record eeeh
you only get permission for the first
recording Wow yeah and then you got
Dylan back by doing wagon-wheel
yeah and giving them more money yeah do
you remember the first time I came on
stage with you guys he's been on stage
so much I do not remember that no yeah
still trying for you lands maybe
wetlands I think the first thing I
remember the first but what I do
remember was in my ear in my headphones
I'm here in this awful sound and I know
it's for percussion it's not it's like a
symbol but it's not really a symbol and
I'm like what is that and I look over
and they had taken the tambourine from
Dan because he was trying to destroyed
they'd taken all the drumsticks from him
Snickers and they've taken a shaker so
he had resorted to taking a rubber
chicken and beating the hell you just
and it was the worst sound ever I I was
angry at you guys and then all of a
sudden if my mic was on I'll be singing
here's Darius and he's got you know 15
20 thousand people in front of him and
I'm trying to get his attention by
singing you know he's not playing my
rhythm he's not playing mine it was only
the one time I took my shirt off and
that was when we were in Scotland and
then what I realized how white you
really are yeah and that's because Sony
would take off his shirt you guys had a
video where he has his shirt off playing
the drums yep and I thought that would
be funny if he looked over and I had my
shirt off
I couldn't sing half a song that day
because for more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]